Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Arrow mid season finale
video so many WTF twist some exciting, some
really crazy.
Some explain everything.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet walking into the arrow cave what
do you see Christmas present haven't seen a long
time.
What's going on what I missed so Stephen Amell
was actually talking little bit about this
twist will explain what he said in some of
the context the dads with the producers have
said is been a lot of people talking about
it giving us kind of an idea for which direction
they're going to take it.
Just a quick reminder that there is a flash
ring giveaway going on right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video.
Make sure you enable alerts so that you don't
miss out on anything during the break, but
I'll remind everyone at the end of this what
the schedules going to be like when everything
is coming back like flash and all that stuff
here we go top 10 WTF Prometheus Joker scene.
so this is like right out of suicide squad
him just laying all those knives out just
crazy style talking to Artemis and looking
at the board of team arrow members that he's
going after so his mission is to just make
Oliver miserable but Artemis is out for his
blood like she totally think that Prometheus
is going to kill them.
So they did a really good job in this episode
of balancing that WTF twist like oh my god
shits is going crazy with the lighter hopeful
moments that you would expect from holiday
episode.
They kinda did that in the flash last night
too, so if you look at this board like there's
an X through Quentyn's face what I think that
means is is that he has, just completely messed
with Quentyn he hasn't killed him, but he
pulled that crazy trick on them where he gashed
his arm and had the throwing stars made him
think made us the audience think that Quentyn
might be behind it all.
So that was just him, just completely screwing
with Quentyn.
So took a little on the episode but that's
basically what it means when he crosses out
one of these team arrow members here.
So they jump you know number nine to the big
holiday party scene where Thea and Oliver.
Remember the crossover last week meeting their
parents again having to lose them out reminded
them of all the things that they're thankful
for.
So they try to be kind of hopeful about Oliver
drops a couple of the Easter eggs in a my
favorite Christmas movie is diehard which
it should be diehards a great Christmas movie
number to the Easter egg he says he re-watched
it's a wonderful life last week which is basically
the plot of arrows 100th episode.
If you've never seen that movie, you should
just check it out during the Christmas.
Sometime during the break just for fun.
But they have a couple nice jokes just like
everybody meeting each other them being awkward
relationship comedy like Felicity getting
super drunk just being really silly like the
whole complex setting that up with Mr. terrific's
husband, so number eight WTF they go outside
Prometheus attacks and then Mr. terrific has to
explain how he didn't run in terror when a
serial killer came along.
So there was kind of this running storyline
where you have Prometheus this trying to drive
everyone away from Oliver or turn them against
him in the team doubling down" No were in
the right place were exactly where we need
to be" you know Diggle the voice of reason
but on the downside of that Mr. terrific's
husband does leave so tangentially Prometheus
is actually been pretty successful in his
mission.
Just create complete chaos within the team.
So number seven they figure out that Justin
Clayborn is connected because of the drug
and Mr. terrific system they flashback to
season one in a new scene.
So if you guys didn't know Justin Clayborn
was only mentioned in the pilot because he
was on Oliver's list.
He was never in an actual episode of arrow.
So all these flashback scenes in this episode
were brand-new.
But they were shocked to look like that happened
in season one.
So like Stephen Amell was like I really enjoyed
putting the hoods costume back on but he said
that the season one costume is his favorite
costume.
So they have this big action set piece classic
season one.
Take down you have failed the city you know
gives in the one day but I love that they
use the big belly burger bag as the transition
just because that was a big set during season
one if you guys don't remember they shut a
whole bunch of scenes inside a big belly burger
restaurant but in present-day things are slowly
starting to unravel inside the group.
So number six Billy starts to figure out that
Mr. terrific is working with the green arrow.
He's a pretty good detective.
So he just refuses to just let the green arrow
handle it throwing him into Prometheus's path
that he gets that text with the baby picture
out before Prometheus gets them so big surprise
number five they analyze the ashes the Prometheus
was keeping and then the picture just confirms
that it is his son.
His illegitimate son but we don't know what
is name is we haven't seen with the mask off.
So we don't know if this is a character we've
ever seen before but it sounds like someone
that is totally new just the way they set
him up.
Like, Oliver being super trigger-happy or
arrow happy however you want to think about
it in the flashbacks biting him in the ass
in the future that's why they had that Diggle
scene you know Oliver dropping bodies gotta bite him in
the ass in the future, so that is what led
to the creation of Prometheus, but number
four they had that really fun Felicity flashback
that shot to look like a season one Felicity
Oliver seen so this scene between them is
brand-new but like all the other flashbacks
in the episode it was made to look like it
actually happened during season one.
So number three Oliver goes in for the kill
back to the factory and have is really cool
transitions where they flash back and forth
in real time to what Oliver was doing as he
was initially going after Clayborn with all
these bodies laid out in the exact same way
that they were in the flashbacks and he fights
his way to the top, but number two as he kills
Prometheus.
It turns out surprise WTF twist that it's
Billy Malone and he asked to go back and tell
the team.
So this is like long dark night of all those
shippers souls like you can't really come
back from this, but the way they play.
It is a very Capt. America Civil War type
twist where the Russo's said that when they
were editing Capt. America Civil War it's
all about Iron Man versus Capt. America who
do you think is in the right.
So different edits of the film would test
differently with audiences like people would
say Capt. America's right know Iron Man's
right, so they edited the film down until
it was 50-50 until about half of the people
thought that Iron Man was in the right in
half of the people thought the Capt. America
was in the right.
So that's kind of the way they played it with
Oliver killing Billy they wanted to feel like
it wasn't totally Oliver's fault, but he still
killed the person that Felicity was in love
with, so there will be consequences like even
Felicity isn't running for the door like it
doesn't seem like she's going anywhere is
much as she's in grief right now like Diggle
said, the team is not going to split up over
this were right where we need to be but another
surprise WTF twist number one as he comes
back to the arrow cave seen Laurel is alive
just like hey what's up bro Diggle is re-captured
by the police being taken back to prison,
so everybody's freaking out, the team is kind
of broken up a little bit.
Although not broken up in the way the Prometheus
really wants them to break up, but what about
Laurel that's really like the thing I feel
like most people are talking about.
After this episode is she really alive Stephen
Amell, kind of address this.
He said that there would be a vetting process
when they come back in episode 10, the team
will be like okay we have to verify whether
or not this is really Laurel because they
see all kinds of twist, they just had the
crossover episode where they were all in a
dream.
They've seen the Lazarus pit.
They've seen people come back from the dead
to the gonna have to verify how Laurel is
still alive, is this an alternate universe
version or is she being pulled from out of
time like somebody went back in time and brought
her forward so the other thing that.
A lot of you are asked me about on twitter
is whether or not somebody slipped something
into Oliver's drink like Susan Williams did
something to him to make him hallucinate,
but because Stephen Amell said, the team would
vet hurt that means that the rest of the team
can see her meaning that she is actually real
she just another version of Laurel.
So my top two picks are one Laurel pulled
from another time or two from another universe,
but let me know in the comments which version
of Laurel do you think that this is and what
do you think the gonna do with her in the
back half of the season because episode 10
is also where Talia al Ghul debuts in the
flashbacks the Russia flashbacks.
So about that, Oliver said that he was trained
by a woman in Russia.
That's probably who Talia al Ghul is going
to be league of assassins training without
actually being at the league of assassins.
So this is the actor's this playing her.
I don't know how many episodes that she's
going to be in or how many episodes Laurel
is going to be in, but at least for episode
10 you can see how their kind of taking Diggle
out of the team for the time being.
So there can add Laurel in for just a little
while.
So it can be a lot of fun.
I'm really happy with the episode.
I feel like that that a lot better job this
year.
So next big question what you guys think of
this half of the season on arrow so far and
do you think it'll be even crazier in the
back half now that Oliver can refocus on Prometheus
and we have Laurel back just like so much
stuff going on, but that's typically what
they do during midseason finale's like even
on the flash they reveal like the big mystery
and they tease what's gonna be happening in
the future like savitar gave them that prophecy
and then showed them what was going to happen
to Iris So I don't want to talk too much about that.
Just in case you guys haven't seen the flash
episode all at a link to that at the end of
this, but what can happen is is arrow episode
10 will be January 25 the flash will be back
that week.
So like all the DC shows are back that week
so I'll just remind everyone when I do bonus
videos I have a whole bunch of flash bonus
videos plan.
But if there any arrow videos that you guys
want me to do just let me know in the comments
everybody wants to talk about Laurel.
So, what the freak out about that for little
while but just reminder that legends of tomorrow
midseason finale is Thursday night because
the Spider-Man trailer is dropping right then
I'm not can oppose my legends video till Friday
morning.
So just a heads up about that you know no
worries, I'll announce the winner of the flash
ring giveaway that and I will keep doing the
giveaway even during the break.
So no worries about that get hype I'll be
posting a flash bonus video tomorrow about
the speed force in savitar I was going to
do that this morning.
But then they dropped the Spider-Man teaser
and everyone was freaking out so it is been
a really awesome week for comic book television
while you wait for that to post you can click
here for that Spider-Man trailer video and
you can click here for my flash finale video
you so much for watching everybody high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow!